foreign
Byron joins us up next in Colorado
Springs Byron welcome to the show
hey there guys really appreciate you
having me on absolutely
so yeah here's a situation uh kind of
lost a lot of money in the stock market
put my family in debt I've got a wife
and three kids so kind of disappointed
what happened but
um long story short
um you know during the stock market boom
and I believe it was 2018 2020 with
GameStop and AMC uh kind of got into
stock market with that uh made a lot of
money
through the options trading of the stock
market and didn't really know what I was
doing so I brought 60 000 to about 130
000.
and then lost it all
and so that's kind of where it gets a
little bit fishy too I started trying to
make it back took out a 25k loan put in
the stock market lost it all
and that's kind of where we're at today
um I've got a car loan for about 40K
we're about 7K in medical debt
uh 5500 in the credit card payments and
we've also got our mortgage to pay for
so
I really dug myself in a hole guys and
really looking for help or else
I'm sorry to hear about this man this
that you you touched about the hottest
stove you could touch and I hope you are
done with playing with single stocks and
options trading especially which is one
of the riskiest versions of trading
there is out there
yeah I'm done with that completely now
what's your income
under 20K per year okay and is that
household is your wife working outside
the home
I know she is a stay-at-home mother okay
what kind of work do you do
engineering defense Contracting cool is
there any opportunity to to work more to
clean this up
uh yeah I would be willing to look into
that I just I guess I don't really know
what would be feasible with time and
opportunity costs I haven't really
explored that option and that 25k was
that a person alone how did you take
that out
to use correct okay so if I'm adding
this up correctly are we talking about
close to 80k or so in debt Consumer Debt
I think after we calculated we're around
98k actually I probably might have left
a few things out of there okay okay one
option
is to get rid of the car because I would
clear 40K that would clean up half your
debt tomorrow what does the car worth
uh right now we currently own about 40K
on it
um I I believe I checked out CarMax in
their cash now offers about 35 000 I
believe okay do some more homework on
that check with a bunch of different
dealerships check private party value
because if you can get 40K for that and
you get any money in the bank anything
in savings
no there's anything non-retirement
yeah I was going to ask is the stock
money completely gone there's nothing
left
it's completely gone okay all right so
that puts you at this baby step one
which is we got to get a thousand
dollars in the bank as soon as possible
do you have that
uh next paycheck yes we can do that okay
beyond that we're gonna start to pay off
all these debts smallest to largest
regardless of interest rates and the car
obviously would help clean this up even
if you took a small loss on it it would
clean this up obviously you need another
card you guys have another vehicle you
could use or could you buy a a cheap
five thousand dollar car
uh yeah we've got family in town and I'm
sure we could definitely use one of
their cars for a bit because right now
it feels overwhelming and I think
getting rid of this car would
emotionally and financially benefit you
and you can always get that car later
and do it with cash and do it the right
way
okay
so that is one thing you could do I'm
just giving you options here are you
currently investing at all in anything
uh we have our retirement account that's
untouched so let's how much have you
been contributing to that
um so
I guess before I lost everything at the
stock market I was doing the company
match so I was about eight percent but
then when everything kind of went
down
um I stopped contributing and just tried
to start using all the money to pay the
debt so we're not doing that anymore
okay let's keep that paused until we get
rid of all this Consumer Debt and we
have a fully funded emergency fund of
three to six months now make it the good
news is you have a great income you make
120k and you've got 98 000 in debt now
if we clean up the car that leaves you
with about 58 and now you're going all
right I make 120k and I got 58 to pay
off how quickly could we do that how
much could you set aside from your
income having paused all the Investments
at probably what 30 40K a year towards
this debt
yeah
um I guess my only concern would be our
mortgage is currently 3 000 a month so
it's a pretty big chunk and what's your
take on pay
7 200.
that is that's a hefty chunk and that's
on a 30-year
yes
yeah you're looking that's 42 we need to
get this income up basically yeah sudden
suddenly selling the car is not an
option we need to do that this is a
necessity yeah
because right now you're not going to
have a lot of margin to throw at the
debt if half of your income is going
towards the mortgage alone that's right
Byron you're going to have to do
everything you can you're going to have
to work more and I know we talked about
it earlier and it was like oh what's the
opportunity cost at this point it
doesn't matter you need to pick up you
need to be working 80 hours a week if
your wife can pick up work if she can do
something inside of the home to earn
money you guys have really got to get
that income up here's the good news
you've got a lot of small debts so
you're going to be able to feel those
wins quicker I hate debt but I like when
it's broken up like this because you can
feel the winds and you start doing a
budget man we're gonna give to you one
year of every dollar premium to get on a
plan you're gonna start selling stuff
you're gonna start finding money in the
couch cushions the kids are going to get
involved this is going to be a family
affair to get this debt out of our Lives
once and for all and you'll never look
back man you'll never dip your toes in
those Waters you learned his lesson of
those volatile single stocks and uh man
that's a tough situation